you tweeted something that I don't even
know if you thought it was racist it
certainly was it was not my friend
rosean bar was on uh Bill Mah's podcast
uh talking about another way it's not
just through censorship it's not just
through big Tech it's also that they
will come for your jokes if you just
tell a joke that they happen to not like
they will try to take you out and
remember what was it five years ago now
when they did the reboot of rosean bar
sitcom it when they it was called the
original one was Roseanne and then I
think the the reboot was called the
Connors it was the number one sitcom In
America when they brought it back number
one sitcom comedy in America she made
one offhand joke no one in their right
mind thinks that she's a racist she made
one off-hand joke and they cancelled her
well here she is uh telling Bill what
she thinks about people who do that sort
of thing back what is it 20 years later
10 years later something with 20 the
reboot of the zitcom goes to number one
again try that b and then you tweeted
something that I don't even know if you
thought it was racist it certainly was
it was not well okay well I thought the
was white I know that's what you
thought but that doesn't mean it isn't
racist because obviously she looks just
like the picture you're not going to get
yourself out of this by by reiterating
and everybody's in power got to be made
fun of that's true mock mock mock mock
mock you if you can't take a joke
you you fascist that's how I feel Bill
and you know what I don't give a what
color your ass is if you ain't doing
right for your own people or anybody's
people in this country where people are
sleeping in the streets and it makes me
sick then you I don't give
a about your feelings you are
offensive to me you better take care of
the people living and dying in these
streets off I'm so sorry but it
just came out no I'm glad that's what I
want I want it to come out it's what do
what do old friends do when they get
together a lot of beeping bleeping you
know what's funny about the bleeps look
at my finger that's from the bleeping
you see that I have a broken finger from
all the F bombs just kidding it's not
from the F bombs I was playing
basketball last night 15 points by the
way hit five threes my team did lose in
the playoffs but I broke my finger right
at the I think it's broken it looks like
it's broken something ain't right it's
not really yeah that it actually does it
look worse on television than it looks
in anyway I'll be all right don't worry
I'm a lefty anyway it's okay last Lefty
thing about me is that I write it with
my left hand but anyway what brings
Roseanne Bar and Bill Maher and Dana
White and Elon Musk and Tucker Carlson
and me and you together maybe it's true
truth maybe that The Human Experience is
so deeply connected to truth that when
they assault us and assault us and
assault us all we've got left is f you
so whether you like Dan santis or you
like Trump at least let's really figure
out what and who the enemy is let's
figure that out then we can deal with
the political stuff so that's like the
space that banino and I are work in
between right now like we happen to have
different candidates at the moment but
we are united on we are united
via something that is much bigger than I
like this guy you like this guy we have
to save this country this is the last
chance so let's go ahead and do
it